What are your thoughts or concerns about
Wearing these wearable type tracking devices such as the garbage devices
That track your exercise level track your heartbeat track your things
Well, my first
Respond to be it's probably giving it off a lot of e-mf's, but actually I tested
Some of these devices a couple years ago, but I don't know which brand it was
But you could get a little e-mf's e-mf testing device and you could test those devices some of them don't give off hardly any e-mf's at all
So I was kind of you know pleasantly surprised
I think I don't think the one that I tested was a garbage. I think the person had I
Can't remember what was the other device that was really popular for a long time
But it didn't really give off many e-mf's so it was fine to use if that's what could
Stimulate you to get in your steps or get in your walkie or check your you know your heart rate on a regular basis
You know, it can be very beneficial. So
There are you know you certainly are getting a whole lot more e-mf's from your cell phone
Also regarding heated vests and heated jackets again, you'd have to check those devices the negative about heated vests and heated jackets as they have it a
heated
Like a coil
And it will it may not produce a lot of e-mf's, but it does produce a frequency that can
Interfear
That's where there's been there was a lot of research on heated blankets the same way because the the heat of
Wire goes through the blanket or through the vest, you know, they're going back and forth and back and forth and back and forth
So it's producing like a frequency that may not be beneficial for your body
And that's why we recommend the heating pads that are the
The ones that we sell which are the are
Infrared heating pads they don't have that heat coil
So yeah, I
You know again, you have to weigh this out. I mean if you're wary that every day
It's probably not a good thing, but if you're gonna go ice fishing or something like that
And you want a heated vest and you're gonna do it, you know, you know once a week or something like that
I just don't think that's you know a major problem